[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen pizza rezept und
nicht irgendein pizza rezept sondern ein
flitzer rezept aus dinkel und weizenmehl
und das mehl habe ich selbst gemacht das
heißt ich habe dinkel und weizenkörner
genommen und die gemahlen und hier haben
jetzt eine richtig tolle vor allem super
knusprige pizza ich weiß du magst du
nämlich sehr gerne
ja ich bin manchmal eigentlich also der
typ ich mal tief luft hier leichte pizza
aber ich finde auch diese pizza richtig
genial also die ist wirklich sehr dünn
ausgerollt und wirklich schön knusprig
um den pizzateig herzustellen könnt ihr
euch einen tag vorher in der küche
stellen den pizzateig vorbereiten und
wenn ihr wisst mensch morgen möchte ich
pizza tag machen dann mache ich das eben
ganz schnell der ist super einfach in
der herstellung dann stell dir in den
kühlschrank und habt am nächsten tag den
fertigen teig für die pizza ist wirklich
cool ist ehrlich sagen ja zu gebrauchen
aber du wirst begeistert sein du darfst
gleich probieren
genau ich habe sie dann noch belegt aber
zuerst einmal zeige ich euch jetzt die
zutaten für den pizzateig und mich den
pizzateig gerettet haben
für den pizzateig brauche ich 100 gramm
weizen kanal 100 gramm dinkel körner 140
gramm hefe wasser 4 gramm salz und zwölf
gramm olivenöl zuerst einmal nehme ich
jetzt die körner das heißt die firma und
die weizenkörner und ich habe hier eine
getreidemühle macht das ganze jetzt in
der mini ihr könnt auch die große
maschine nehmen auf jeden fall
und jetzt wird es einfach fein gemahlen
jetzt ist der ton heller das heißt das
korn ist vollkommen gemahlen wir warum
sind ausschütteln
und jetzt kann ich die getreidemühle
entfernen und die reste noch hier mit
rein geben
jetzt muss ich daraus einen vorteig
herstellen das heißt ich lebe jetzt hier
das hefe wasser mit dazu und jetzt wird
alles gut durchgeführt und dann werde
ich jetzt abdecken und 20 minuten lang
stehen lassen
jetzt ist der vortrag so weit jetzt kann
ich den pizzateig weitermachen ich gebe
jetzt in pizzateig wieder zurück in die
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt ihr
natürlich auch mit der hand weiter
kneten jetzt füge ich hier noch das salz
und das olivenöl hinzu und knete jetzt
daraus kurz einen hefeteig
jetzt habe ich den teig zu einer kugel
und gehen jetzt in die gefettete
schüssel zurück decken ab und lassen
jetzt für etwa 16 stunden im kühlschrank
ruhen
und dann kann ich morgen die richtig
leckere pizza hut
so sieht der pizzateig jetzt aus ich
habe jetzt hier einfach mal eine portion
entnommen und wetter jetzt gleich zur
pizza weiterverarbeiten
ich nehme da jetzt einfach einen belag
denen ich einfach vor dem kühlschrank
hatte dass ich habe den kühlschrank und
den vorratsschrank geplündert wert ist
eine ganz einfache tomatensoße
zubereiten und dann noch ein bisserl was
drauflegen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
pizza soße brauche ich eine dose tomaten
100 gramm tomatenmark hier habe ich noch
gewürze und zwar einen teelöffel salz
etwas pfeffer jeweils einen esslöffel
basilikum und oregano und etwas chili
einige redner snowboards ehe und für den
belag nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen zu
giacomo rat zu leben habe ich noch
paprika büffel mozzarella und einfach
zwiebeln den pizzateig werde ich jetzt
ganz dünn ausrollen also dass wir
derzeit eine andere pizza wie die die
ich schon auf meinem kanal habt die
andere pizza etwa er seiner luftigere
etwas ludwig gezogen ja das wollte ich
nicht so schön aber bis am 8 und das
hier wird jetzt noch schöne dünner pizza
und wenn ihr meint datei ist dünn genug
dann nehme ich jetzt meine back folie
denn darauf kann ich noch ein bisschen
dünner ausrollen
die habe ich übrigens mal zurecht
geschnitten also nicht wundern was jetzt
die back foley so klein ist den teig
dass ich jetzt hier kurz stehen und
werde jetzt schnell die soße
zusammenrühren das heißt einfach alle
zutaten vermischen
wir nehmen möchte gerne noch eine prise
zucker die hatte ich eben vergessen
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass ihr
nicht zuviel füllung drauf gibt denn das
soll eine dünne große pizza werden und
die durch die jetzt eben nicht mit der
tomatensauce ertränken
das heißt ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen
was und verstreicht es schön glatt was
ein bisschen brand frei
jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen belag
drauf da nimm dir einfach belag der wahl
für mich kann es auch vegetarisch sein
morath marx kennen mit zu doch ich
glaube ich mache jetzt halb halb
[Musik]
beim z4 zeit sind im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 240 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 10 bis 13 minuten aber das ist
eigentlich bei spaghetti jedenfalls ist
jetzt die pizza fett ist jetzt hier
unter zehn cool dieser politik
knuspriger sollte richtig knusprig aus
jetzt gibt vor allem ist das hat echt
mal eine tolle alternative zur weiß mit
pizza und jetzt muss ich echt sagen kann
man wieder öfter
die nächste pizza hole ich gleich raus
jetzt schneide ich sie soll ich dich
fragen ob du die vegetarische und hatte
hier zog variante möchtest
[Musik]
bitteschön okay ich probiere jetzt kein
fotos okay ich mache ich noch mal eine
okay
als nur eine bonus extrem blind sie
letztlich extremwinter bonus ok und
nicht schlechter so einfach anders der
teig schmeckt einfach also der tag hat
schon einen eigenen geschmack durch das
selbst gemahlenem mehl hat wirklich
richtig tollen geschmack und es passt
perfekt zur tomatensoße also echt gut
[Musik]
muss man mit samira und ihre freundinnen
machen
er ist es mehrmals am tag vorher
natürlich für gartenarbeiten töten
wollte stücke vor lecker darfst du gerne
ich wollte euch noch sagen dass diese
pizzateig sehr vielseitig ist das der
bitrix sehr vielseitig ist denn man kann
daraus zum beispiel auch leckere cracker
backen
das zeige ich euch dann aber einfach ein
nächstes mal jetzt hoffe ich dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat probiert
dieses pizza rezept auf jeden fall mal
aus ist etwas ganz anderes vor allem
finde ich hab ja nicht so ein schlechtes
gewissen wenn man wirklich immer noch
405 weiß nimmt ich hatte mal echt ein
gesundes medien hat dinkel mit dabei hat
weizen vollkommen mit dabei und das ist
echt echt ein richtig tolles rezept und
vor allem kann man den teig super
vorbereiten und ja nur ein paar kalorien
bedingt war
das kommt vom samstag gibt kein zurück
und ich hab kein brand also viel spaß
und nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal das
rezept findet ihr auch cf - blog.de
und falls es mal ausprobiert dann
schreibt uns auf jeden fall wie es euch
geschmeckt hat ja ich denke du kannst
damit auch mit kohle süße pizza machen
mit schoko und bananen schmeckt bestimmt
auch sehr lecker weil das einfach super
dazu passt der tigers von frank o da
kann doch flammkuchen machen also echt
toller tag wirklich sehr sehr lecker
bis zum nächsten mal das
mittelalterliche hbw sonst sterbe ich
[Musik]